MALE SPEAKER: Welcome.
LISA WRAY: Hi.
ANNIE LIEN:
[NON ENGLISH SPEAKING]
RICHARD FULCHER: I'm Rich.
MARK YEH: [INAUDIBLE]
Google Play to Mark.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you so much.
It's great to be here.
STU ANDERSON: My
name's Stu Anderson,
and I'm part of the Google
Play for Education Team.
BETHANY FONG: Hi.
I'm Bethany, a
designer at Google.
YASMIN GREEN: One
of the things we're
trying to do over
the next decade
is to end repressive censorship.
MALE SPEAKER: What's
my next appointment?
PHONE (ELECTRONIC SPEECH): Today
at 4:00 PM, Android Automotive
monthly update.
MALE SPEAKER: This is
an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm going
incorporate one more
element so let's dive in.
MALE SPEAKER: The show featuring
actionable startup advice.
MALE SPEAKER:
Welcome to the lab.
MALE SPEAKER: Gigabyte.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK, guys.
Seriously.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
that's pretty awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: Build better apps.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, come on.
Really?
MALE SPEAKER: That's
it for this time.